KAREN: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I'm here to welcome Ellen
Sussman, local author.
Ellen is the author of the
nationally best-selling novels
"French Lessons" and "On a Night
Like This." She's the
editor of two anthologies,
"Bad Girls: 26 Writers
Misbehave," a "New York Times"
editor's choice and "San
Francisco Chronicle"
best-seller; and "Dirty Words:
A Literary Encyclopedia of
Sex." She has published
numerous essays and
short stories.
Ellen teaches creative writing
both in private classes and
through Stanford Continuing
Studies.
She has two daughters, and
lives with her husband in
northern California.
ELLEN SUSSMAN: Thank you, Karen,
for inviting me here,
and introducing me.
And thank you guys all for
coming, and whoever else is
out there listening in for
listening in today.
I'm really pleased to be here.
It's also my first visit
to the Google
Campus, so I was wowed.
It's been-- and lunch
was really yummy.
So today I'm going to talk about
my latest novel, which
just came out at the
end of March.
So kind of hot off
the shelves.
And it's called, "The Paradise
Guest House."
And I think that what I will do
first is tell you how this
novel came to be.
It's very different from
my other novels.
And then, I'll read a little bit
from it, and then it's up
to you guys, because I would
love your questions.
That's always, to me, the most
interesting part of these
discussions, because it tends
to make it more new for me.
And we can go in all kinds
of different directions.
But I'll start with where
the idea came from.
Do you all remember
the terrorist
attacks in Bali in 2002?
Yes?
I'm getting mixed responses
to that when I've--
I've just finished
a book tour.
And I remember it as
such a big deal.
And I think a lot of people
kind of missed it.
It might be that it was a year
after 9/11, and we were still
absorbed with our own healing.
But it was an absolutely
horrific terrorist attack.
Bombs were set off at two
nightclubs in Bali, killing
over 200 young people--
as in 20-somethings--
mostly Westerners.
A great majority were
Australian kids.
And it devastated Bali,
as you can imagine.
Anyone here been to Bali?
So I had always wanted
to go to Bali.
And after those terrorist
attacks, that
went on the back burner.
I wasn't going to
go for a while.
And a few years went past, and
my husband and I started
talking about let's go back,
let's plan that trip.
His father had been to Bali
years before, and talked about
it as paradise, which we've
always heard Bali as talked
about a kind of paradise.
So we-- in 2005, we
planned a trip.
And three weeks before we were
set to leave, there was a
second set of terrorist
attacks.
And these were smaller.
They only--
only--
20 people were killed.
But they were set up in
the same sort of way.
They were at tourist restaurants
and cafes.
And they had the same sort of
effect, which was to send to
the tourist industry--
to destroy the tourist industry,
and to crush the
Balinese people in
substantial ways.
Neal and I decided not to cancel
that trip, and I'm not
quite sure why.
But we felt very strongly
that we should go.
And when we went, our experience
in Bali was so
unusual, we did not see one
tourist in two weeks.
Not one Westerner.
So hotels were completely
empty.
Beaches were empty.
Restaurants were empty.
The Balinese tend to eat in
different restaurants than the
tourists eat in.
So this fabulously gorgeous
country was kind unmarred by
ugly tourists.
And it also gave us a wonderful
chance to talk to
the Balinese people.
And I'm not sure we would have
had that same opportunity.
We got their stories on what had
happened in 2002, and what
happened just three
weeks before, and
how they were affected.
And for some reason--
I've never written a novel that
is based on a historical
event before--
but for some reason, this kind
of got under my skin, and
affected me in a very
profound way.
And as I started to think about
it, I think there are a
couple of things that
were going on.
One is that Bali is paradise.
I mean, you can't imagine
a more gorgeous island.
It's got those white, pristine
beaches, and crystal blue
waters, and lush mountains,
and terraced rice paddies.
It's heaven.
And the idea of these terrorist
attacks in paradise
just didn't make sense--
not that we could make great
sense out of the World Trade
Centers, but at least you could
kind of figure out why
that would happen, right?
And the other thing that made
no sense to me was the
Balinese people are the most
peaceful, loving, religious--
their religion is Balinese
Hinduism.
The rest of Indonesia is Muslim,
so Bali stands out as
a very separate part of
Indonesia, which might have
had to do with the terrorist
attacks.
But I couldn't make a connection
between the
Balinese people being a target
of these attacks.
And as--
I have one writing student
here-- as my writing students
always hear me talk about,
I tend to write to learn
something, rather than
to spout out
everything I already know.
So I think I wrote this book
to try to understand those
disconnects that didn't
make sense to me.
And the end of the--
I should throw in here-- one
of the reasons why I think
that works very well, especially
for fiction, is it
means that I am writing with
a driving need to discover
something, and that will kind
of push the forward momentum
of the book.
I'm trying to learn something.
So my reader will also have
that sense of needing to
discover, needing to learn.
Whereas, I think if a writer
knows everything about their
subject, knows everything that
they're going to tell in the
story that they're setting forth
to write, there will be
a kind of dryness or a lack
of energy in those pages.
So I actually loved the idea
that I don't understand
something, and that I create a
fictional world in order to
understand it.
So by the end of the two weeks
that we were there, I had this
idea that I would write about
a young woman who is in Bali
on business--
a young American woman--
and she gets caught
in the terrorist
attacks, and is injured.
And a year later, she returns
to Bali for a one year
anniversary healing ceremony,
and also she is looking for
the man who saved her
when she was there.
And that was sort of the
germ of the idea.
I didn't know how I was
going to go about it.
I'll tell you quick
side story.
I called my agent
at that time--
I still have the same agent--
and I told her this
idea all excited.
And she said, no, no, no, no,
do not write that novel.
I said, why not?
And she said, Americans do
not care about Bali.
And I said, really?
She said, no, you can't write
about foreign countries.
Americans don't care about
foreign countries.
So this was in 2005.
Two things, I think, have
changed, and changed--
I didn't come back to
writing this novel
till five years later.
And I think two major
things changed.
The biggest one-- does anyone
know why Bali--
"Eat, Pray, Love."
So "Eat, Pray, Love" came out
in 2006, proving my agent
completely wrong.
And suddenly, Americans are
wildly interested in Bali--
so much so that when
I went back--
I went back in 2010 to spend
a month to do much
more serious research--
and now the island is filled
with tour buses of young
30-something women looking for
spiritual enlightenment, or
Javier Bardem.
And it's kind of awful.
I still love Bali, but you
have to avoid the EPL
syndrome, is what they call it,
and how much this fairly
untouched piece of paradise has
been changed by tourism.
And the other thing that I think
did change is that I
think Americans finally kind of
got outside of themselves a
little bit, and started to think
about what's happening
in other countries finally.
So I had put this book
on the back burner.
A real quick aside--
I came up with another
idea for a novel.
I had lived in Paris for five
years some years ago, and I
had an idea for a novel.
I called my agent, and I said,
here's a new idea.
It's three Americans in Paris
on one day all each walking
the streets of Paris with their
own French tutor talking
about love and loss and Paris,
and all kinds of things.
And I said, it's three novellas
connected that way.
And she said, no, no, no,
don't write that novel.
And I said, why not?
And she said, I can't
sell novellas.
not--
will not work.
So that one did not
let go of me.
And I just thought, until I come
up with the next idea, I
might as well just write this
one, and ignore her, even if
I'm just twiddling my
thumbs and keeping
myself out of trouble.
So I wrote that novel,
and by the time I was
finished, I loved it.
I was really happy with the
world that I had created.
And I sent it to her, and I
said, here's my novel about
three Americans in Paris.
And I never used the
word novella.
She had completely
forgotten the
conversation that we had had.
And she read it, and loved it.
A writer's dream is what's
called an auction.
So when an agent goes out with
a book, they go to many
publishers.
And our more realistic dream
is that maybe one publisher
will make a bid on your book.
And with "French Lessons," nine
publishers were bidding
on the book, so it
went to auction.
And in the end, the two
publishers that were still
fighting for it--
a day later, I decided to
sweeten the offer by making it
a two-book deal.
So my agent called
me up, and she
said, this is so exciting--
quick, do you have an idea
for a second novel?
And I said, yes, how about a
young woman who goes to Bali
and gets caught in the
terrorist attack?
She said, that is brilliant.
No recollection.
So that became part of the
two-book deal, and I finally
got to write my Bali novel.
After I read from it, I'll tell
you a little bit about
the research that
went into it.
Again, as I said, I've
never done--
written a novel that has so
much research involved.
But it so much depended upon
what actually happened in Bali
at that time, and an
understanding of Balinese
culture and religion, and all of
those things that I knew so
little about.
So we'll get to that part.
I'm going to read from the--
it's actually the second
scene in the novel.
Jamie, the young woman,
has just arrived--
the first scene is she's on the
plane landing in Bali with
all of her fears and
reservations.
And in this next scene--
well, you'll see what follows.
"When the taxi jolts to a stop,
Jamie's eyes fly open,
and for a startled second
she catches a glimpse
of Gabe in her dream.
No, it's something more
tactile than visual.
His fingers drawing circles
on her hip.
The smell of the sea
and his hair.
She clears her mind
with a shake.
'This is the street,' the
taxi driver says,
patiently waiting for her.
Jamie had been wide awake at
the start of the hour-long
taxi ride Ubud.
She watched the hordes of
motorbikes fill the streets,
rolling down the windows to let
in thick, tropical air.
And then sleep kicked in--
hours on international flights,
and she couldn't doze
for a minute.
10 minutes in a beaten
up jalopy without air
conditioning, and she
was comatose.
'Lady,' the taxi driver says.
He is young, and smells
of ginger.
On the dashboard are prayer
offerings, probably to the
gods of pothole roads with
too many motorbikes.
'Thank you,' Jamie says, paying
the man, and hauling
her suitcase out of the car.
She stands on the sidewalk
and looks around.
She hadn't visited
Ubud a year ago.
She'd stayed in Seminyak for the
first few days, and then
she spent three days in a beach
cottage somewhere until
she could flee the country.
But Ubud is the home of Nyoman,
her host for this trip
down memory lane.
The foundation that organized
the one-year memorial event
sent her a packet with his
name, his address, and an
itinerary of events leading up
to the ceremony on Sunday.
She'd also received
a plane ticket--
a gift from the government
of Bali.
She'd been promised
a new Bali.
Jamie looks around.
People swarmed the streets, and
she feels the immediate
exhilaration that always
marks her first
day in a new country.
But it's mixed with something
else, something that chills
her skin despite
the damp heat.
I can do this, she tells
herself, in the same way she
has argued with her
mother for weeks.
I have to do this.
She reads the name of
inn on the piece of
paper in her hand--
the Paradise Guest House.
She walks by a series of modest
cottages, some of them
with stone gates and elaborate
carved entrances, none of them
with names.
She feels someone's
eyes on her, and
glances across the street.
A young boy sits on the
dusty curb with a dog.
The boy is mangy, the
dog is mangier.
The boy boldly keeps his eyes
on her, and after a moment,
his lips curl into a grin.
Jamie offers him a weak
smile in return, but
thinks, leave me alone.
The boy stands, and within a
second, the dog stands, too.
The boy is probably 12, Jamie
guesses, and wily.
He looks smart and vigilant, and
she suspects that he's a
street kid.
Or maybe all kids in Bali
look like this.
She has no idea.
She doesn't know this country.
She doesn't want to
know this country.
But isn't that why she's here?
'I help you,' he calls from
across the street.
'No thank you,' Jamie
calls back.
She hurries down the road,
pulling her small suitcase
behind here.
But in a quick moment, he's
beside her, offering to take
the suitcase, his
hand on hers.
She pulls away." "'I'm
fine,' Jamie insists.
'You want nice hotel?'
he says.
Do kids speak English here?
Is it possible that last time,
in one whole week, she never
saw a kid in Bali.
She saw the inside of her hotel
room, beach-side bars, a
mountain trail.
She saw Gabe standing in a
garden, his feet lost in a sea
of orchids and gardenias.
'I don't need help,' Jamie
tells him, her
voice a little sharp.
'Everyone need help,' the
boy says smiling.
In fact he has not
stopped smiling.
He is tall, and he smells
like earth and rain.
His dog walks at his
side like a shadow.
It's a skinny pup, some handsome
mix of black lab and
border collie.
Jamie sees a sign
outside a gate--
'The Paradise Guest House.' The
sign is painted gold with
black letters.
She turns abruptly down the
path, hoping to lose the boy.
But he's quick, and again
reaches for the suitcase.
He must be looking for a tip.
'I've got it,' she
says testily.
'Good-bye.'
'You are tired',
the boys says.
'Tomorrow, you will be nicer.'
She nods, unsure
how to answer him.
He opens the gate for her, and
lets her pass through.
'I see you tomorrow,
miss,' he says.
As he closes the gate, she
takes a deep breath--
jasmine.
The gate shuts out the noise
from the street, the boy and
his dog, the hot
sun, the dust.
Her eyes adjust to the cool
darkness, and a tropical
garden emerges thick
with banana
trees, ferns, and hibiscus.
She follows a path through the
dense foliage to a small stone
cottage with a carved wooden
door, where she lifts a
knocker in the shape of a
monkey and lets it fall.
A hollow, booming sound
interrupts the silence.
She waits.
After a moment, she knocks
again, louder this time.
Finally, in slow motion,
the door creeks open.
A man stands there, his hair
tousled, his clothes rumpled.
Did she wake him?
He blinks at her, and runs
this hand over the
front of his shirt.
'Can I help you?' he asks.
His accent is better
than the boy's.
He adjusts his crooked glasses
and peers at her.
'I'm looking for Nyoman.'
'You've have found him.'
'I'm Jamie Hyde.' He
stares at her.
'I received a letter from the
organization that--' Jamie
pulls open her small backpack,
and rummages in it to find the
letter.
'Yes,' he says, even before
she finds it.
A smile breaks through the
creases of his face.
'Welcome.'
'Were you're expecting me?'
'The man is silent
for a moment.
His hand goes to his head, and
he rubs it vigorously.
When he's done, his hair swirls
on his head, making him
look a little crazy.
I should leave, Jamie thinks.
But oddly, she takes a
step closer to him.
'Tomorrow, you are coming,'
he finally says.
'I'm sorry, I thought
it was--'
'You are welcome in my house.
I'm often confused.' His smile
transformed his face.
He's probably around
40, Jamie guesses.
And though he's badly in need
of some grooming, he's a
handsome man.
'I can find some place else
to stay tonight.' Jamie
unconsciously touches the scar
on her face, and then she
tucks her hand in her pocket.
Nyoman reaches for
her suitcase.
'Follow me.'
He walks past her and
out the door.
But instead of passing through
the gate, and delivering her
back onto the unfamiliar streets
of Abud, he walks
around the house and toward
a series of small cottages
behind his own.
Two young boys stand in front
of one of the cottages, both
with toy trucks in
their hands.
They stare at Jamie
open-mouthed, and then turn
and run, screeching as they
disappear into the trees.
'Nephews,' Nyoman says.
'One is loud, and the other is
louder.' He is still walking
past one cottage, and
then another.
A very old woman, her skin brown
and wizened, sits on the
ground in front of one door.
She smiles a toothless
grin at Jamie.
'Grandmother,' Nyoman
tells Jamie.
He says some quick words in
Balinese to the old woman, and
she giggles like a young girl.
At the fourth cottage,
he stops.
Wisteria spills over the front
of the house, it's pale violet
blossoms filling the air
with a pungent scent.
The ground in front of the
wooden door is covered with
petals from the flowers,
a blanket of color
as a welcome mat.
'Your home,' he says.
Jamie feels something unwind
inside her, something that had
been knotted tight since she
agreed to this trip.
'Thank you,' she tells him.
'Now you rest.
The flights are very long.
I come to get you when it is
time for your dinner.' He
pushes open the door,
and light pours
into the single room.
Jamie can see a four-poster
bed with mosquito netting
draped over the top.
A wooden bureau with
a mirror above it
sits next to the wall.
The room is simple and clean.
She takes a step inside.
When she turns around,
Nyoman is gone.
Standing in the doorway, she
gazes out at the garden.
There are lights in
every cottage.
His family, she assumes.
She smells incense and she
hears a rooster crowing.
It is as if she stepped behind
the wall of Ubud and found a
different country.
My home, she thinks.
Her real home in Berkeley is a
room in a ramshackle Victorian
house that she shares with three
other adventure guides,
all of them usually somewhere
else in the world.
And her mother had just moved
out of the Palo Alto home
Jamie grew up in.
'I don't want all those memories
of life with your
father,' Rose said, when Jamie
begged her to keep the house.
'I was there, too,' Jamie said,
like a pouting child.
She's 32.
It shouldn't matter where
her mother lives.
Maybe it's her homelessness that
makes her pine for that
childhood bedroom.
Or maybe it's a yearning
for all those dreams
only a kid can have--
parents who stay together for
a lifetime, boyfriends who
don't die, night clubs
that don't explode.
She hears the sound of
someone singing.
It's a woman's voice,
high and sweet.
The words must be Balinese
or Indonesian--
Jamie can't really tell the
difference between the two
languages--
but she hears something so
haunting in the song that she
feels herself back away
from the door.
The woman's heart is
broken, she thinks.
She closes the door, and
the sound stops."
So I think I'll take your
questions, and then we'll see
where that leads us.
Pressure's on you now, guys.
AUDIENCE: Is this--
first of all, thanks
for coming.
I thought it was really
interesting how you were
talking about your interaction
with your agent and the
auction, and how just saying
that one sentence of an idea
could give a yes/no
or a book deal.
And I was wondering how that
was different from when you
first started writing, and just
getting out there in the
first place.
ELLEN SUSSMAN: That's
a good question.
In the beginning, when you're
first trying to sell a novel,
you can't do anything
unless you have the
entire novel written.
Nobody will buy a book
idea for fiction.
For nonfiction, I've sold
two nonfiction--
I've published to nonfiction
books, and those were both
sold on proposals.
So you come up with the idea,
you write an introduction, you
write a table of contents,
you come up
with a marketing plan--
which is mostly made
up, or a dream.
And then your agent sends that
off, and you actually get your
advance based on a 25-page
proposal, and you haven't
written the book yet.
But with fiction, until you've
established a name for yourself--
and oftentimes, even
after that point--
you have to write the novel
basically on spec, and then
see if you can sell it.
So I have at least two novels
that never sold--
probably three.
It's a grueling business that
you have to be completely
dedicated to for some
crazy reason.
And I say crazy, because
it's very hard to make
a living as a writer.
It's very hard to sort of fit it
in to real life in terms of
jobs, and a regular
career path.
I'm now making a living
as a writer,
but I started writing--
I decided at age six I wanted
to be a writer, and was sort
of singularly pursuing that, and
then dedicating my life to
it from age 21 on.
But I didn't start making a
living as a writer until I was
48 years old.
And then I'm really lucky.
I mean, I have lots of writer
friends who can't support
themselves on their writing.
So to get back to your question,
you spend this crazy
amount of time writing this
novel because you somehow
believe that you've got
a novel in you.
Then you have to find an agent
based on that novel, and then
the novel--
then the agent goes out
to sell the novel.
So in the first novel that
I published, that was the
process that I went through.
Once I published that novel and
developed a relationship
with my agent, I can now
run ideas by buy her.
As you can tell, I don't
listen to her.
And she kind of doesn't
listen to herself.
I catch her in one mood,
and it changes
to a different mood.
I am now finishing the
novel that will be
published a year from now--
it will be published
a year from August.
And in that novel, we sold it
based on the first hundred
pages, and that's the first
time I've done that.
So "Paradise Guest House"
was not written at all.
It was sold based on that one
line, because it was a
two-book deal.
For the next novel, I wrote a
hundred pages, and then my
agent went out to sell it.
So I feel like I'm very lucky
that I can have that sort of
vote of confidence in advance.
Although, of course now I'm
worried that I'm not going to
deliver the novel they think
that they bought.
We writers worry about a lot
of things all the time.
But it is a crazy business.
And it's a really risky
business, as a fiction writer
especially, because
the big idea does
not translate, right?
That when I said "French Lesson"
was a three novellas.
It is no different than the book
that I finally produced,
that hit the "New York Times"
best-seller list.
But the description of that
book is nothing--
three Americans walk the streets
of Paris with three
French tutors, right?
That doesn't tell
you anything.
Nobody would buy that book
based on a pitch.
So that only works in the
execution, of the writing of
the novel, and whatever happens
in the storytelling.
Whereas in nonfiction, you can
pitch, I'm going to write a
book that explores this, that,
or the other thing, and the
publisher will have a fairly
good idea of what it is
they're going to receive.
Fiction, just-- we don't have
that luxury usually.
AUDIENCE: So in this book,
you were going explore--
you wanted to learn, right?
So at the beginning, did you
know how the book was going to
go and what happened?
ELLEN SUSSMAN: No.
Was the mic on?
Did you hear that?
OK, great.
I don't write with an outline,
and it's for very much the
same sort of reason that
I write to discover.
Because I think if I know
everywhere that I'm headed,
the juice is gone.
I want that sort of desperate
need to know.
So the book that I just sold to
my publisher that's coming
out next year, page 100 ended
with a kidnapping.
And I was very scared that my
editor, or the publishers,
were going to say,
so what happens?
And I would not have been
able to answer,
because I had no idea.
And I had no idea until page
300, really, what would
happen, which kind of kept
me going in that way.
So with "Paradise Guest House,"
I knew that I wanted
this woman to--
who is very damaged.
I set her up, as you could tell
from that reading, as an
adventure guide.
She's very gutsy, independent,
worldly 32-year-old.
And I did that so that
this trauma would
affect her that severely.
You take somebody who is out
in the world, and makes her
living being out in the world,
and make her scared to step
out of her house, and that
is big trauma, right?
And big drama.
So I set her up as an
adventure guide.
I have her traumatized by
the terrorist attack.
And I then want her
to deal with it.
So she's got to go back to Bali
to struggle through this
to move forward in life.
And something had happened there
with this American man
expat who saved her.
And I knew that I wanted them to
reconnect to find out what
that was all about.
And I didn't know what would
happen when they did.
And I didn't know how
she would deal with
being back in Bali.
So those are mysteries to me
that I follow with the same
sort of curiosity that
I hope the reader
brings to it, right?
And then, by trusting the story
that I'm creating, and
the characters that I've put
on the page, I kind of let
them lead to me--
doesn't it sound sort
of woo-woo?
But I'm trusting them to lead me
to where the right place is
for them then to go.
So one of the things that
I did need to do--
I mentioned the research trip.
Sounds like a tough job
for a writer, right?
Got to go to Bali for a month.
And it was fabulous, but it
was also really hard work.
I knew that I needed to get the
taste, sounds, smells of
Bali, right?
To fill the book with Bali.
I also needed to talk to as
many Balinese people--
expats--
to find out about daily
life in Bali.
Gabe, the man she's looking
for, is an expat.
I needed to understand why
expats move to Bali, what
their concept of paradise
is all about.
So those are the kind of
easier things to get.
The harder things
for me were to
understand Balinese Hinduism.
The Balinese believe
in reincarnation.
So if you believe in
reincarnation, do you grieve
the loss of a loved one in the
same way that if you don't
believe in reincarnation?
And I don't know.
I don't understand that.
So I really needed to learn a
lot more about that to be able
to include that as part
of the novel.
And Bali was desperately
trying to heal.
Bali as an island was
desperately trying to heal
from the terrorist attacks.
And to do so, their religious
life affects their daily life
in every possible way.
So I needed to understand the
culture, the religion, and the
family life.
And that meant doing some book
reading and internet research,
but it meant more talking to
the people who I met there.
And then lastly, the most
interesting part of the
research that I did
when I was there--
I met a woman from Berkeley
who moved to Bali 25 years
ago, and married a Balinese
prince, and has been doing all
kinds of good work.
She runs an organization now
that started in 2002 for the
survivors of the terrorist
attack, and the families of
the victims.
And its to help them heal, and
to educate the kids, and to
get money for the-- the Balinese
who were injured in
the terrorist attacks were
mostly the people
working in the clubs.
In fact, one of the clubs that
was bombed didn't even allow
Balinese people into the club.
It was just for Westerners.
So the people who--
the Balinese who are injured
in the attacks tended to be
poor, hard-working, struggling
Balinese, and
people on the streets.
When the attacks happened, and
everyone was rushed off to
Sanglah, which is the
one major hospital.
First of all, there's no burn
unit at any hospital in Bali,
and the hospital was completely
inundated and
overwhelmed.
So they immediately flew out
all the Westerners to
Singapore and to Australia.
And the Balinese were left
with these inadequate
conditions for healing
in Bali.
So the woman I met suggested
that I might want to talk to
some of the survivors and
the families of victims.
So my last three days in Bali,
she set me up with a driver
and an interpreter, and we drove
all round Bali to the
worst part of the inner
city, to these
very remote poor villages.
And I met with a woman who's
just covered with scars from
all the burns and the skin
grafts that she's had.
And while we talked, she had
her baby climbing all over
her, and this huge smile
on her face.
And she told me her horrific
story, and I had tears
streaming down my face.
And another woman who lost her
husband in the bombing--
he was just riding by
on his motorbike at
the time of the bombing.
And she told the story about
waiting for him to come home
from work that night.
And she could no longer
talk after a while.
And her daughter who was in
high school came up on her
motorbike, and joined us
and took over, and told
the story for her.
And ended up by saying, and
now she's studying to be a
doctor to make sure there are
doctors on the island who can
take care of the Balinese.
These were amazing stories.
They didn't go into the book,
but they informed everything
that I put in the book, because
I was learning about
the Balinese spirit.
I was learning about the truth
of what happened, and how--
I just got a fan email.
And truly, fan emails-- like,
you write a book, and you give
it to your friends and your
family members, and they have
to say they love it, and you
don't believe anyone.
But if someone who lives in
Oklahoma takes the time to
send you an email, and you don't
know this person, and
they just finished reading the
book, and they thought they'd
write you--
that is amazing.
So my fan email is like my
highlight of every day.
And I got one last week from a
woman in Oklahoma who had been
a first responder at the bombing
in Oklahoma City at
the courthouse.
And she said that I got the
description of the bombing
absolutely right.
And I was so pleased.
That was something I was
very scared about.
I've never been in a bombing
before, and the two main
characters race into the
nightclubs when it happens.
So I really needed to spend time
describing all of that.
So I think that it was a
mixture of all of those
stories that I heard, and the
time that I spent trying to
get the human story, more
than anything else.
It's not about--
in fact, at its core, this is
probably a love story, but
it's a love story with terrorism
as a backdrop,
because it has everything to do
with how people heal, and
how people find each
other when they are
going through trauma.
So I needed to understand
all of that in a way.
I could not make the love story
work, I could not make
Jamie's process towards healing
work, unless I really
understood what it was that
they went through.
We have time for another
question or two.
Someone else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In your research,
did you find that the
Westerners healed differently
or processed it differently
than the Balinese?
ELLEN SUSSMAN: It was
one of my burning
questions the whole time.
Knowing that reincarnation is
such a strongly held belief--
core belief--
for the Balinese, I really
needed to get that.
And it's so hard for us as
Westerners to understand that.
So there's a line in the book
where it turns out that
Nyoman, the owner of the
guest house, lost
his wife in the bombing.
I'm not giving much away.
That comes-- we learn
that fairly early.
And he talks to Jamie a lot
about his experience.
And he keeps explaining to
her that his wife will be
reincarnated probably
as his child, which
is what they believe.
Isn't that amazing?
So he has to have children
so that she
has a chance to return.
And I talked to somebody
there who--
they absolutely--
they had a baby.
A healer came and told
them that the soul of
the baby was the--
I think it was the mother or the
grandmother who had been
killed in the bombing.
So they feel this
very strongly.
On the other hand-- so Nyoman
says at some point, but I
still have a hole in my heart.
It doesn't mean that the
loss disappears.
There are still grieving for
someone who was central to
them, and whom they loved.
But I think it gives a much
stronger sense of continuity
of healing that that person
will come back, that the
circle continues that we
don't necessarily have.
And yet, I don't think
it relieves you
of the pain of loss.
And there's something--
one of the things that I have
only figured out, kind of in
retrospect.
Now that I've published three
novels, and I can look back on
those novels, I see that
there are themes.
There are issues--
let's call them obsessions in
my life that I will write
about over and over again.
And loss is the big
one for me.
I lost both my parents
at a young age.
And no matter what I'm writing
about, loss comes in.
And it comes in kind of
through the back door.
If I were to sit down and say,
I want to write a book about
loss, I don't think I could
create the human story.
But because of the fact that I
am always kind of confronting
my own feeling about loss, and
how do you move on when you've
lost a loved one?
When my characters are
struggling with loss,
everything I know about that
pours into the book, right?
It informs my characters'
reactions, their experiences.
And I think that is kind of
the way it has to work in
fiction, that we can't
do it as consciously.
We have to do it sort
of subconsciously.
And then it will feel more
organic, and less
manipulated, right?
It's not like we're the puppets
pulling the strings.
We're creating real characters
who have human emotions, but
those human emotions will
often come from our own
obsessions, our own
life issues.
And loss is that one for me.
So I'm always surprised.
I'm at the point with the new
novel that I'm writing now--
that I just finished
a first draft--
and it's after I finished a
first draft that I look at it
and say, what's that
all about, what
am I writing about?
And once I can identify what I'm
writing about, I can dig
deeper, and I can try
to explore it more.
But on that first time through,
I don't go there,
because I want it to be coming
not from here, not from my
mind, my intellect, but coming
from my heart and
soul somehow instead.
AUDIENCE: What's the
best advice you've
ever gotten for writing?
I'm asking selfishly.
ELLEN SUSSMAN: Well,
I'd say two things.
I am one of the most disciplined
writers I know.
So I think the best advice is
to stick your butt in that
chair every damn day.
I mean, it is so hard,
especially through the years
when you're not succeeding.
And I had plenty
of those years.
And you're filled with
self-doubt, and everybody else
in the world--
we were talking earlier.
I moved to Silicon Valley 20
years ago, and everybody I
knew was in the hi-tech
industry, and I would talk
about writing and people
were like, what
are you talking about?
What is that all about?
So you feel lonely.
You feel isolated.
You feel crazy.
Nobody--
especially if you've been
successful through school and
grad school, and you won all the
awards, you then think, OK
world, here I am.
My 20s were such a shocking
revelation to me that the
world was not waiting
for Ellen Sussman.
And I couldn't figure out what
the hell happened if I was
supposed to be a superstar, and
instead I could barely get
a story published.
So suddenly, all of that noise
in your head is what it takes
up-- that's what takes up all
the space in your head.
And somehow or another, you
have to sit down and work
every day, and push that noise
out of your head so you're not
living with self-doubt, or
you're not living with the
voice of your mother saying,
go be a lawyer.
All of those things, and you
somehow have this ridiculously
cocky, irrational belief that
you have the right to tell
this story, and you should
write that book.
So that's probably the most
important thing, is to make
the space for writing the book,
is to create your life
in such a way that
you can write as
close to daily as possible.
And then the other thing that
I almost always advise
everybody is to get a day job,
because it just is so hard,
and it takes so long, and it
puts so much pressure on you.
If you can figure out a way to
do a day job that doesn't take
away all of the time and energy
for fiction writing.
But the most important
is just sitting
your butt in the chair.
Thank you all so much.
[APPLAUSE]